foreign
do you know training a classifier to
distinguish beverages can help predict
the cuisine of an image to know more
about cancer learning and how it works
stay tuned till the end of this video
in this video we will cover topics like
what transfer learning is how transfer
Learning Works moving forward we will
dive into why you should use transfer
learning after that we will cover the
steps to use transfer learning and at
the end we will see popular model
trained using transfer learning let me
tell you guys that we have regular
updates on multiple Technologies if you
are a tech geek in a continuous hunt for
the latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from sip leader
by the end of this video I can ensure
that all your questions and doubts
related to transfer learning will have
been cleared also accelerate your career
in Ai and ml with our comprehensive
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning boost your career with this Ai
and ml course delivered in collaboration
with party University and IBM learn in
demand skills such as machine learning
deep learning NLP computer vision
reinforcement learning generative AI
prompt engineering chargedy and many
more you will receive a prestigious
certificate and ask me anything session
by IBM with 5 Capstone in different
domains using real data set you will
gain practical experience master classes
by Buddy University and IBM experts
ensure top-notch education simply learn
job assist helps you get noticed by
Leading companies this program covers
statistics python supervised and
unsupervised learning NLP neural network
computer vision Gans Keras tensorflow
and many more skills so why wait enroll
now and unlock exciting Ai and ml
opportunities the course Link in is in
the description box below so without any
further Ado let's get started so what is
transfer learning transfer learning is
machine learning refers to G using a
pretend model to improve prediction on a
new task it involves using knowledge
gained from a previous assignment to
tackle a related problem for instance a
model trained to recognize backpacks can
also be used to identify other objects
like sunglasses due to the substantial
CPU power required this approach is
widely utilized income Division and
natural language processing tasks
including sentiment analysis so moving
forward let's see how transfer Learning
Works so how does transfer learning work
in computer vision neural network have
distinct objectives for each layer
detecting edges in the first layer and
identifying forms in the middle layer
and capturing tasks specific features in
the later layer transfer learning
utilize the early and Center layers for
a pre-pretent model and only retrains
the later layer it leverages the label
data from its original task for instance
if you have a model trained to identify
backpacks in images and now want to use
it to detect sunglasses we will retrain
the later layers to understand the
distinguished features of sunglasses
from the other objects so moving forward
let's see why should you use transfer
learning transfer learning offers
several advantages including reduced
training time improved neural network
performance in most cases and the
ability to work with limited data
training a neural model from scratch
typically requires a substantial amount
of data which may not always be readily
available transfer learning becomes
valuable in such scenario here is why
you should consider using transfer
learning first one is efficient use of
data with pre-trained models you can
perform well even with limited training
data that is specially beneficial in
tasks like NLP where obtaining large
label data set can be challenging and
time Computing the second one is faster
training building a deep neural network
from a scratch of a complex task can be
time consuming taking days or even weeks
by leveraging transfer learning the
training time is significantly reduced
as you start with a model that has
already learned General features from a
related problem now moving forward let's
see steps to use transfer learning the
first one is training a model to reuse
it in machine learning training a model
involves providing it with the data to
learn patterns and make prediction once
a model is trained on a specific task it
can be reused and repurpose for related
tasks saving time and computational
resources the second one is using a
pre-trained Model A pre-trained model is
a model that has already been trained on
a larger set for a specific task instead
of training a model from scratch using a
pre-trained model as a starting point
allow us to benefit from the knowledge
it has gained during its previous
training the third one is extraction of
features feature extraction is a process
in which meaningful patterns and
characteristics are identified and
separated from a raw data in the context
of machine learning it involves
identifying relevant information from
input data to feed into a model for a
better prediction the fourth one is
extraction of features in neural
networks a neural networks feature
extraction involves identifying
important patterns or features in the
data at different network layers the
early layers typically capture simple
features like edges while deeper layers
capture more complex feature relevant to
the task at hand this hierarchical
representation enables neural network to
learn and generalize from the data
effectively
so moving forward let's see some popular
models trained using transfer learning
so numerous machine learning models have
been trained using transfer learning
some popular ones include for the first
one is
vgg16 and vgg 90.
these models were trained on the image
net data set for image classifications
test the second one is inception V3
these models were pre-trained on
imagenet and are known for their
effectiveness in which rapid in object
detect repeat in object detection and
object recognition the third one is bird
bi-directional encoder representation
from Transformer this language model is
written on the extensive text collection
and find extensive application in NLP
tasks like sentimental analysis and name
entity recognition the fourth one is GPT
generative pre-trained Transformer
series these models are printed language
models for various NLP tasks
these are just a few example of
pre-trained models that have been used
in transfer learning to accelerate
training and improve performance across
different tasks and with that we have
come to end of this video on what is
transfer learning I hope you found it
useful and entertaining please ask any
question about the topics covered in
this video in the comments box below our
experts will assist you in addressing
your problem thank you for watching stay
safe and keep learning with simply
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign